Many conservatives saw the Brexit
referendum and Donald Trump's 2016
victory as useful correctives. It was
time to push back, the argument went,
against the overreach of unaccountable
international bureaucracies, such as the
European Union and the UN. Maybe
even NATO has become obsolete.
But can we really go back to an age of
sovereign nation-states? Not really.
For example, ten million US flags are imported into
the United States from China every year,
and a tightly integrated global economy
needs shared rules. Although reforms
of many international organizations are
needed, Western democracies cannot
disengage if they are to keep the
world's authoritarians at bay.
Also, the age of sovereign nation-states is
mostly a myth. Throughout its history,
Europe was marked by efforts to
reconcile diversity and unity through
federalist projects, such as the Holy
Roman Empire or the Hanseatic League.
Those long predate the creation of the
modern nation-state in the late 19th century.
Globalism is thus not a historic
aberration — nationalism is.
To learn more about my take on nationalism
and globalism, check the link in the
description below. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.